people in Africa look at Europe in two
different ways I think for some people
it's a place that almost looks like
paradise it's a place where you can have
a job you have you can go to good
healthcare you can actually you know
study etc but for others it's also a
place of very little opportunities
I think what has happened increases
entry is a very good example the world
has changed and some of the ways in
which things are being done hasn't been
updated so it's it's really a really
leadership challenge for the Europeans
to really think very hard about how to
make the continent sustainable again and
I think it's going to be difficult
because most people are used to the
comfort
my name is Eddie Kaku and I'm co-founder
and CEO of entrepreneurial solutions
Partners which is an adversary and
investment firm looking to use
entrepreneurship to create prosperity in
Africa in the Caribbean
what I would wish for is for Europe to
think about Africa as an equal partner
because Africa has something to
contribute
I would really invite the Europeans
training of it through learning and the
way you learn is you visit Africa you
visit India you visit other parts of the
world that are doing this you know
better certain areas if you look at
what's happening around the pre-crisis
or every time there has been a crisis
it's basically one country that that
almost feels singled out
it's really that sense of connectedness
which makes society work because you
think of solutions that are not only
individualistic but solutions which
actually touch the community they need
to be returned to the original idea of
the community I mean it's called a
community for a reason I think Africa
can teach a lot to Europe about how you
build communities literally I mean in
southern Africa the collodion bull - you
know I am because you are
today it's about you know how do we
build walls which are very very high and
how do we screener if it is better had
we sort of send them back to where they
come from faster and I don't think
that's the solution I think the solution
is to really look at ways in which you
make Africa prosperous because when that
happens then it's going to create an
afro for those refugees not to go
when we talk about prosperity is not
just wealth I think it's wealth it's
happinesses health gates security it's
like living a good life according to
one's definitions when you start looking
at it with more comprehensive memory you
know begs the question I mean can you
really make the case that your average
the peon is happier than average African
I don't know
you